hi i'm chelsea handler i'm here to read
buzzfeed's
thirst tweets
chelsea handler is extremely hot and
beautiful and cute
and also a genius and also a wonderful
person and a brilliant creator just
wanted to say that on record k
bye well she sounds like she wants to be
in a relationship with me and i am
willing to be in a relationship with her
because
that's the best review i've ever gotten
i'm this is a woman and i just want you
to know if you're watching
there's chemistry already all i need in
order to like someone is for them to
like me
i have a celebrity crush on chelsea
handler i would let her rock my world
and leave me
like it never happened i would love to
be able to say that i could rock a
woman's world
actually i probably could you know what
i think i could it's still
out there i don't i'm still not locked
down into any commitment so anything is
on the table
if you could quarantine with any
celebrity who would you choose
i would choose chelsea handler she's
funny sexy and always has weed this is
true i always have weed like you will
never come to my house first of all that
will never will never run out of alcohol
i have a tap and you will never run out
of weed there's weed
everywhere and every guest room i have
goodie bags for people unless of course
they bring children and then they're not
allowed in certain rooms
everything you could possibly need for
six months is here
and i have a really nice outdoor area
too where we can socially distance
chelsea handler can handle me any day
i've heard that one
and it's actually chelsea handler could
handler me
in any way that's what they wrote in my
high school yearbook or maybe i wrote
that i don't remember
i want chelsea handler to roast me and
then punch me in the face uh i would be
happy to do that sir
i want chelsea handler to cuddle me in
peru while i cry and puke on ayahuasca
i've done that already in a special for
netflix where i called chelsea does
drugs where i flew to peru and i did
ayahuasca and they warned me not to do
it because they said
oh people who go and do ayahuasca you
know vomit
on camera you're going to vomit and
possibly your pants and i was like
i don't think i'm going to eat my pants
i'm too advanced
for that i'm not going to ruin a buzz by
defecating on myself
and guess what i went to peru i did
ayahuasca i did not get my pants you
know who shot his pants twice
the shaman is it just me or is there
something really sexy about chelsea
yeah no it's not just you there could be
something sexy about me
let me know when you find out what it is
in a white woman divorced two years ago
living next door kind of way lol yeah i
should have finished that tweet
i am white i'll admit to that oh diddy
tweeted that
i went off on p diddy you know what he
was three hours late to my show chelsea
lately i'll never forget that he was
three hours late to the taping of
chelsea lately and i just
ripped him a new one i think it was on
camera too so you could probably
reference it
chelsea handler's boobs are my favorite
thing literally
of all time so fantastic thank you
i love my boobs as well and i think
everybody knows that at this point
i had to free the boob phase because i
had a boyfriend who told me that my
boobs were too big and that it made me
look fat
and he said they were inelegant and when
he said that it made me want to cover up
my boobs and then once we broke up i
whipped them out and i haven't taken
them
i haven't put them back since chelsea
handler's butt
is greater than kim kardashian's nothing
is greater than kim kardashian's but
i've seen it up close
and personal and mine i'll show you is
like a little baby
nugget never been much of a cougar
chaser but i would totally let chelsea
handler do whatever she wanted to me
just saying what's that noise that
cougars make no
no that's a cat right that's it rare
gross
i think you have to have children to be
a cougar or no you just have to go out
with younger guys i don't have that
problem either
i don't mean to be gross but i'd munch
chelsea handler's butt
that doesn't sound so bad compared to
some of these other tweets i'll take you
munching my butt
if that's a commitment you want to make
good luck looks around
tl sleep chelsea handler needs to sit on
my face you know i will girl
you know i will i'll sit on almost
anything chelsea handler my woman crush
i'd lick a homeless man's balls
to have drinks with this [ __ ] i'm not
going to have drinks with anybody that's
licked anyone's balls recently
whether they're homeless or they have a
house thank you buzzfeed
please make sure and watch my hbo max
stand up comedy special
evolution
[Music]